hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Kraven Manor now like
neverending nightmares I played this
game originally about a year back and it
was amazing and awesome but it was an
early build supposed to be a playable
demo woo woo them a nightmare mode more
challenging you explore the matter with
a mechanically powered flashlight and
[ __ ] with in a more deadly yes because
I have played this before and I don't
know how much was added in the new
release on Steam I mean it's a paid
version now as opposed to a free version
about a year ago so I'm assuming that
it's the full game that came out at
least that's what other people have told
me and everyone out there who has asked
me so thank you all so much for
suggesting this game in the first place
and yes there are mannequins in it if
you remember it's one of those games
that I don't like because it's got
mannequins in it not that because bad or
I don't like the gameplay but I don't
like mannequins in general hello oh I
need you oh wait no okay let me explain
something about this game that makes it
interesting if you see in there that's a
model of the world inside the house so
as I go into rooms and now there's only
one over there that has a room attached
to it as I go into there I'm gonna find
another room of the house in the house
that the room is in and then I'm gonna
put it on the thing in the house that
the room is in but take it out of there
and put it down and then the new room
will be out in the house and the model
there it is in there we go I guess the
game wanted me to move on so anyway so I
have a flashlight it's mechanically
powered I'm assuming I shake it like a
shake weight and nothing bad will happen
to me hello there my old friend I know
what happens to you in the end are you
shining
why are you shining oh you got no face
I'd preferred that way okay so there are
clues in the game that kind of tell you
what to do I think I remember that with
them before unless I'm totally mistaken
but they think I know about them the
heat does not reach far into this cold
room and it was less than comforting
this house is supposed to be abandoned
yet something
the fire why does it have to be
something I can't be someone so I need
to find the piece of the puzzle of the
house and the puzzle of the piece of
piece and it's gonna be lying around
here somewhere
hello ah dumbwaiter uh well that's gonna
be good I need to find another way
around now excuse you
someone doing some late-night drilling
over here something I should be informed
about okay
so man it is so weird playing these
games that I have played before clear
boundary between sorcery and the mere
illusions of mentally ill women okay
then sexist much others well alright
then sorry to disturb the entirety of
the library
I see it's snowing pieces of paper
that's lovely I'll just be on my way
oh that's my flashing okay Kai what
happened
oh god the lights went out I was doing
that already
oh and my good friend moved along I
don't know why I want to come
all right there Oh oh that's right
because you have your pieces you store
there and then you got to move them
along up to where you want them to go
now I can rotate them such that it does
that and boom I got a house oh they took
the library away so anyway this is how
this game works you build the house
however you want to build I can put the
room over there I can put the room over
there I don't know if that was fully
implemented before because I seem to
remember there was a certain way things
were supposed to go so let me put it
down where I just was oh hello yes I got
a key ding ding ding ding ding dong
anybody home and it's supposedly
abandoned the place let me try this
again I'm just gonna move this so I
don't have to go upstairs for this funk
thank you Mikey go hello thank you I
need this key this for things it's out
to my flesh either oh that's me doing my
shake weight flashlight oh okay oh okay
ah the cellar I remember you think all
notice to Kraven Metal Works employees
thieves and layabouts okay the leaves
and layabouts shall be disciplined by
Lord Kraven and shall receive no wages
during recuperation yeah I remember now
this is where I first found the
mannequin ah all right then ah seems
I've torn this painting into dozens of
thin fine scratches oh that's good
Gordon do good all right I'll move hang
on there we go it doesn't last very long
but it's quick on the draw off you know
what I mean and then if I know my game
he's gonna be right over here oh don't
do that
hello oh no wait a minute what why would
I need to do that
no is he mobile what the hell what the
hell
oh you god damn it I forgot all righty
then
Hormuz no no hello yeah that's right
that's what I'm supposed to do I
remember now
it's been a year everybody prepare with
me I don't even know if most of you have
seen the original video hmm
that's right oh yeah I remember now it's
so weird play the game that have already
technically played before uh
architecture reflects both scrupulous
detail in extremely strange structural
components get out of my face you
douches ah I drop my key I'll take this
excuse me as I hold everything at once
and crank my yank oh good it littered
itself up in here wait no the light
already happened close up what do I do
with my ornate key can I go home with
this can I make the intelligent decision
yeah the door trembles slightly at my
touch longingly I rubbed my fingers
across as ornate handles and I wrap its
doorknob over and over again over oh no
I dropped the thing damn it damn it damn
it all to hell damn it
wanted to get my ornate key so I dropped
my bags excuse me sorry I dropped this
entire room of the house hope no one
Minds very there is a draught going
through here well alright then whatever
so we're gonna put that where the lost
library was oh wait it doesn't fit
that's right if this one only wants to
go here ah or here or here or here
uh-huh
okay then I'll play your game you rogue
now so far this is the same game that I
played before but I'm eagerly awaiting
for new stuff to come along and I'm
assuming that that morning he is gonna
do something that it hasn't been able to
do before
well by the way do you like my new sound
proofing I finally got it in sound
proofing it's the newest thing won't it
stop stopping like that when it seems
decided hi friend who's the shy guy
behind that door come on out I just want
to play look inside this books are many
diagrams and sketches of human teeth ah
so you're a dentist tell me about your
profession I remember this room yeah
crime scene uh black-and-white photo
depicts a male body on its knees leaning
over with its head submerged in a vat of
molten bronze I'm not gonna go ahead and
explain the story because I already know
what happened in the original game so
I'm not gonna talk know some grunge
[ __ ] want to come over here oh
okay oh excuse me I'm gonna crank it
just seeing all this horn makes me want
to blurry photos of six nude men and
women decorated with streaks of red
paint dancing around a glass orb setting
appears to be top floor of a library
good let's just make sure that all of
the diabolical stuff I uh-huh Oh
how's this a reflection of the landlady
minimal electrical charge huh
decreasing homeless miss an indent in
doubtful pass okay police chief takes
credit I'm sure I'm sure
that they all got jobs and lived happily
ever after
new homes they certainly weren't dipped
in bronze yeah is that nothing okay it's
so weird because I'm playing this a year
later wait oh is this is this a room oh
it's a run I know I know you ain't gonna
get me here what's up oh it's good all
right then
ah ah nonsense and gibberish truth lies
beyond the sleeping man okay anyway I've
been reading my journal
um the [ __ ] lives in the recesses of
darkness
a place between curiosity and madness I
can feel it it seeks to destroy me
so why the hell did I come in here can
you put that away please we got problems
oh it's dark and spooky all right then
wait a minute oh is that what happened
did that do that mislead me cuz I could
have sworn and I could have sworn I got
cornered by really really douchey do
wait what wait a minute what no no no no
the nature of limbo has revealed itself
to me it is a receptacle in the state of
existence where in the spirit can be
contained
woohee then a carefully detailed
illustration of a human arm being dipped
in bronze with a set of pincers labeling
appears instructional as if we were torn
out of a manual what kind of sick
strange manual would that be owner if
anyone's in this attic Oh chuckles ooh
go Duke nope maybe it was afterwards oh
okay okay all right then okay oh we're
good I was so good so happy so happy
that everything is happening again all
over again when I first played this it
scared me out of my mind I'm surprised
that I'm still getting jumped by some of
the scares then again I have the volume
like super loud in my headphones I'm
almost going deaf from the jump scared
noises so let's try this again shall we
where shall we put the attic in the
basement of course oh no I don't want to
put it up there I'm gonna do this I put
it gonna put it right here
oh yes again attic in the basement wine
cellar on the doogee I can't put that
there because there's no room I'll just
leave the wine cellar alone for now
that's game it's cool it was such an
interesting interesting idea I've never
seen it
whoa hello warning keyhole I didn't know
that of course I would have done that
give me that
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme I
did not know you were there you this is
new huh the gear I jumped from I didn't
even jump there this is my excitement
first it out of it gear system appears
to be missing an important piece
looks like it's fulcrum is missing a
left there's another dumb waiter over
here so that was in the library so I'm
assuming I need to take something from
the library put it in the dumbwaiter and
get it going up but are you the way
that's for later I gotta get through
here yay oh boy
what are you should I even ask you
really creeped me to see from a distance
but I'm gonna come towards you I get a
handwritten list of 23 surnames he's
followed by a different thumbprint hmm
could those be the lovely homeless from
the derping doubter area I don't
remember what about tonight
why are you I don't think so
mister ah this is no I definitely don't
remember anything like this happening
before oh that's what I like creepy a
sec could have done that and I gotta go
explore other now I'm gonna put that up
for now excuse me I need it need it
find out what the hell is happening in
the rest of this place before I go up
there ah yes all right then
that looks good wait what wouldn't it do
the same thing I guess I guess just in
case you go around the back way you can
put it down so it doesn't block your
path okay
gosh it's all locked up boy never mind
that I'm gonna go up that's probably the
back way that I would have gone if I had
just gone straight up the ladder here
no one jump out at me please
Rane my least-favorite oh this is no
ball this is all new I don't like it I
don't want ya first certificate of
William Craven Hey
I know I know silly Billy you back up a
step
wherever you are like whoa oh come on
and no those gonna hurt me so yeah I
gotta crank it pump it up a bit back off
you silly sassy sons of [ __ ] what's
with all the many barrels anyway no no
no what is that about
oh I get it hold I've known I didn't see
that so what do I do
Dwight oh oh okay I got it
I gotta throw it all in cuz I'm a man
limit two points oh yeah
let's assemble all the goodies
sorry about the [ __ ] throw line shot
maybe huh and the worst three points
yeah oh is that a good sound let me pull
one morning for good measure just in
case
whoop okay we're good enough so what did
that do
also why did that do okay we're saving
he Anna ah God [ __ ] damn it with the
whoa what was that time oh this is a
candelabra okay it's causing me to panic
okay so shattered window in the
background that leads us this flashlight
holy hell yeah there could be a million
different ways to go about this than the
stupid flashlight
I picked nightmare mode No ah why God
stop hurting me stop it stop hurting me
how do I get outside it's got to be a
way to get outside because I'm assuming
I need to climb through a window come
back round another way oh I probably got
to come back to it it's probably just
another one of those things that I gotta
move back around you little hello lady
oh don't drop them so let's just carry
on get out of here Frank it was odd you
know you do not thank you laughter the
Florence up in darkness what happened
hey I had eyes on him what happened I
had eyes on okay it's weird it's weird
the hell's happening how did I die how
did I die
no okay I'm assuming like cuz he like
vanished just before I got to him soul
must have been that I needed to loop
back around let's just hey-hey-hey with
the thing things falling on my head why
go into this with full manners and not
lose it again we're going go right here
hey hey hey hey how you doing
no you crawly bastard you where am I
going
imma go oh yeah you get out of there
deadly my left foot that's right okay
sounds easy I wasn't too hard now I just
gotta don't do that oh I got the library
back Lana Lee which means that I can
actually put this where it needs to be
and then get the get the cellar back in
place yes now oh good we're doing just
fine except for me because I'm all out
of time so thank you all so much for
watching we're already starting to
explore a bit of new stuff so I'm just
gonna assume that there is a lot of new
content and I'm gonna play this to the
end so either way I hope you guys are
enjoying it let me know what you think
of this game in the description below
and let me know if there is a lot of new
stuff because there might be Easter eggs
I need to find don't spoil anything in
the comments but just let me know give
me a clue where to look so anyway thank
you again everybody for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
come back for another night terrible